[Music]
i think he'd be ready to go that's my
personal opinion i do i think that um
you know he's now i would say this um
because times have changed like you said
times have changed you know in the years
past you you draft a guy whenever you
draft him even if it was that early
you know those guys
would you know
traditionally not play until their
second or third year but really ever
since probably what six or seven years
ago you started seeing more guys playing
early
but i think he has that capability
that's giants offensive coordinator mike
shula he was asked this specific
question as to whether or not rookie
quarterback daniel jones would be ready
to start week one if he were in a
different circumstance the question
implies that he won't start week one in
new york because eli manning is the
starter but chris the more i think about
this and first of all it's probably
smart for the giants at this point to
stop talking about daniel jones but the
more i think about this latest comment
i'm starting to wonder do they have
something percolating that we don't know
about i mean this is the team that
brought us we didn't sign odell beckham
jr to trade him so
there's always something going on behind
the the curtain that we don't know about
and could it be
that daniel jones they liked him enough
to make him the sixth overall pick they
feel
compelled to justify their faith in
daniel jones he's competing with
in theory if it's a competition a
quarterback that we all believe his best
days are far behind him if the giants
are right about their faith in daniel
jones he should be able to win the job
fair and square and be the week one
starter right yeah well no i gotta see
it to believe it i don't you know the
giants have been in eli manning's corner
uh it was so loyally it's loyal to a
fault i mean you know again hey eli
manning the giants they've been to the
super i mean they've been to the
playoffs once since they won the super
bowl in 2011. they went to a wild card
game up in green bay there's not a lot
of starting quarterbacks who can sit
here and say oh i've been a starting
quarterback for a football team for the
last eight years and we've only gone to
the playoffs once and i've led the
league in losses and interceptions
through that timing that that time
period and i'm still the starting
quarterback in the man and the
organization backs me he's so that right
there to me is the first issue and hey
there's been a lot of talk for two or
three years about replacing an eli
manning you know we weren't sure if they
were going to draft a quarterback in the
2018 draft they took saquon barkley
instead because they just felt like they
couldn't pass him up i get it he's that
special uh but daniel jones i do think
and i said this i know at the start of
the show it's physically more gifted
than eli in every category right now
especially arm stronger better athlete
you know got good size he can do it all
and i think what mike schull was really
just trying to say and they're still
trying to push this narrative that
daniel jones was worth the number six
pick too i think this plays into it that
they're he's just trying to tell people
i think this guy has the type of dna and
mentality to where he would be ready
week one if we really needed him to be
but isn't the best evidence that he's
worth the number six pick to let him
compete with eli manning and give him a
chance to be the starter and i can hear
dave gettleman now explaining when the
decision is made in august and and you
know
maybe they soften us up to it as well
maybe that's one of the things they
learned a couple of years ago with the
abrupt benching of eli manning and how
people reacted in part because they were
stunned they already
tipped their hand about drafting daniel
jones maybe they've learned there's a pr
component to this where you have to get
people comfortable with the idea maybe
at some point we're going to be start to
be made comfortable with the idea maybe
the first clue is going to be it's going
to be a competition no no spots are
determined on the depth chart that's all
to be proven in training camp in
pre-season
once we start hearing things like that
chris i'm going to feel even more
strongly that remember that over under
there's a sports book in las vegas
that's set the over under for daniel
jones starts at seven and a half yeah my
first thought was oh that's up yeah but
bet the farm on the under then i'm
thinking they know something and i i may
be the right bet there is the over well
listen you know they they know that eli
manning is at the end of his career
that's the one thing they know i mean
hey it's it's hard to say eli's one of
the best 32 quarterbacks in football
right now to be quite honest with you i
mean that's really it is i mean if you
made me rank him last year i would have
said he was outside the 32 starting
quarterbacks i thought there's backups
that were better than he is so you know
that's that's one thing or one area
certainly but mike here's to me at least
in my experience a guy i know i played
in the football i've been following in a
long time here will be the context clues
i look for in training camp in the
preseason okay if we start to hear
daniel jones is looking great he's doing
awesome in training care and practice
okay that's great that's one clue the
next clue to me though to see if he
legitimately has a chance to play early
on in the season or maybe start a week
one like we're talking about here is how
do they manage him in the preseason
games that's gonna be the thing i look
for if if they think oh gosh this guy's
good and he has a chance to be the
starter week one they will let him play
with the ones or at least play with the
really good number twos they're gonna
script for success more to make sure his
numbers and everything looks good if
they really want him to play if they
don't want him to play they might not
design plays in the preseason to make
sure he looks so good and just let him
learn the basic plays of the offense so
to me those are kind of the politics or
the angles teams take if they're trying
to set it up and certainly something i'd
be looking at hey and then there's the
reality that he simply shows up at
training camp and outperforms eli
manning and everyone knows it i think
back to 2012 when the seahawks gave matt
flynn 10 million guaranteed which was a
heck of a lot more than than it is now
and drafted russell wilson pete carroll
was praised for being so brave to go
with wilson look it would have been
ludicrous for him not to because
everybody in the organization knew
wilson was better than flynn he
outperformed him and that's ultimately
what's going to determine this in
football one of the few remaining
meritocracies if daniel jones plays well
if he outperforms eli manning i think
he's going to be the week one starter
and the thing is at some level the
giants right are going to maybe
not necessarily rig the competition in
jones favor but if it's even remotely
close
they're going to want to show that they
did the right thing in trusting
uh daniel jones as their sixth overall
pick in the draft yeah he should be able
to beat out eli manning at this point
again they're not going to come out and
say it but these are the things we need
to be watching going forward yeah no i i
all your points are right and and and to
what you're saying too i'd be shocked if
that wasn't the case really throughout
training camp i mean you know we talked
about this with the reskins and dwayne
haskins hey players are watching they're
watching film of practice coaches are
talking you know you go through a week
or two weeks and daniel jones is out
there you know just striping the ball
throwing rockets and and spirals and
accurate and and making great decisions
and all those things the players notice
and then you start to get a buzz in the
locker room and all of a sudden the
coaches start to hear hey the players
are they believe in daniel jones and
then that filters up to upstairs and
yeah would the giants give him a chance
if that's the case i'm gonna say no i
think they're going to let eli uh have
one more shot no matter what it's just i
haven't seen anything else but to
believe otherwise at this point they
continually placate to eli and talk
about it and i know obviously they're
trying to move on with daniel jones but
i just got to see the actions come into
play before i believe that the mara
family the tisch family and the new york
giants are not going to give eli manning
every opportunity to start and win some
games early on in the year
i just think it's easier to make the
transition before the season even begins
because
it's just awkward during and it's sad if
you end up benching him during the
season and there's a swan song and what
do you do with him at that point and
that's the other question let's say they
would decide
and and i know this is a big if to make
daniel jones the week one starter what
do you do with eli manning at that point
you've already paid him five million
dollars this year he's due to make
another
half million
in salary that becomes fully guaranteed
if he's on the regular season opening
roster yeah do do you bench him do you
cut him do you
tell him look we know you have a no
trade clause but we've got an
opportunity to trade you a team that
needs a starter right now because of
injury you can go there and play or you
can stay here and not play i just think
there's a lot of chapters left in this
one and um you know once they drafted
daniel jones i i think it was very
common and understandable to say okay
well at some point down the road they're
going to have to have the conversation i
think the conversation may be sooner
than we otherwise
would have thought by virtue of the fact
that he was pick six not pick 17 not
pick 30. right pick six that's the clue
yep that that maybe this isn't a guy
who's gonna sit on the bench for an
extended period of time chris no i mean
i wouldn't think so either you don't
draft a guy at number six just have him
sitting over there you know drinking
gatorade and looking at the clipboard
and telling everybody good job i mean
you're definitely right about that you
want a guy to contribute you hope he
contributes
at least within the first two years and
you hope really ideally it's in one year
um you know i your point about oh would
a team trade for your live manning hey i
think if a team was really good and they
just said okay we're desperate and
something happened in training camp
maybe eli manning would join a team that
he felt was
a quality football team i don't think he
waves as no trade clause unless he felt
like it's a team that was truly a
playoff super bowl contender but the the
the other thing i'd say too is hey even
if they did start daniel jones let's not
forget last year we saw two rookie
quarterbacks get hurt and sam darnold
and josh allen it's good to have a guy
like eli manning behind those type of
guys too in that situation to where your
season doesn't fall apart if the rookie
does get hurt and now you got a veteran
uh veteran you know quarterback to come
in and save the day
boy that would be awkward though yeah
week one right and then called into
action week four week five because the
starter got injured all right we're
gonna take a break when we return we
talked yesterday about sean mcvay's
over preparation in the wrong areas for
super bowl 53 so that leads to this
question of the day which head coach and
quarterback combination would you want
if you were facing bill belichick in the
patriots more pft library after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports